the Joe Rogan experience well you and I
have righteous virtue because we drive
electric vehicles occasionally that's
that's true I do feel a little bit
better I feel better than people when I
Drive my Tesla mm mm you [ __ ] yeah
poisoning the world I you know I feel I
only feel better driving my Tesla only
in that it's just faster it's just
faster than almost everything on the
road yeah it's a time machine
that's the at that's exactly what I call
it I always say like if if there's a
location that I want to go to I appear
there yeah I don't know Jun yeah over
there he's just like and you have that
p100 D yeah it's the one I have which is
the monster one yeah and it's meanwhile
that [ __ ] new thing that they're
coming out with it the Roadster I have a
second faster 0-60 yeah it's oh well
11.9 1.8 theoretically 1.8 seconds here
this thinks he's changed his uh his take
on that I think he recently said its 2.1
are you serious yes okay we're very
disappointed right this way because you
gotta break the two bearings what kind
of nonsense is this
I know where's my point where's my tenth
of a second it ain't going to matter
kids [ __ ] thing's ridiculous I
kidding it's just a [ __ ] weapon yeah
it's it's it's insane but it also has
six hundred mile range yes that's what I
heard which is just insane to me I just
love that it's a tinier car it's like
the fastest thing ever
yes there's only gonna be maybe three
other road-legal cars that you could buy
that would get to that that level one
car tonight they're gonna look obsolete
compared to that oh yeah I mean well the
thing I'm excited about is the
Pininfarina electric car all designed
completely in-house and I don't know
when it comes out but I don't know if
you find a picture it is the nastiest
piece of tech don't let the Italians
make the engine though trust oh yeah I
don't think so I think they're
leveraging like not let my people design
things you let them design the way it
looks but all the wires they're barely
paying attention standard girls asses
heat and spaghetti I guarantee you
that's so funny that's so true you like
Germans and Japanese make reliable cars
you know they make their engineers no
they're good
damn that is a goddamn Batmobile yeah
she'd be nasty wow that's a real car oh
yeah when's that coming out
I think orders are there that went five
million jeez yes that's nice yeah
there's all this money coming active
heiress how many shakes are there I mean
come on
get that [ __ ] at the anti borrows a
little bit of like Ferrari laferrari as
a lot of Japanese styling it has a it's
the perfect blend of like all the good
things about like tech looking car know
what it's like it's like a Ferrari 488
yes but one walk 1911
oh yeah yeah yeah yeah yeah that's yeah
I got that hundred one hundred how many
Newton pounds of torque know what I say
whenever they say that Newton meters I
don't get it those European ones what
are you saying I don't feel it all I
know is what is high and then I base it
off of that it's funny to that we still
use horses I know well stupid as I look
at that see is people power less than
two seconds so that's like the but it's
an electric vehicle yeah I'm sure
biting has one coming out that looks
really cool it 180 miles an hour 186
miles an hour in 12 seconds so 12
seconds later you're going 186 miles an
hour
control cockpit no that's what I like
about cars like that I like better look
amazing it's a [ __ ] house and the
house you know it house in the hills I'd
get it Wow that's right if I could I'd
get it would you oh yeah easily I
definitely want to get the roads of
thinking about the Roadster I'm getting
that [ __ ] you got to man got to I mean
it's not that I mean for 250 grand no
you're getting a car that like that's
that's a what is that was it again but
you keep showing us Jamie you just flip
into you know check out Jamie's on a
route a rabbit hole he went down to
YouTube let's see what was lovest was
doing the other one rope stir oh yeah
that that thing's Bettis what is the
other one Rimac concept - oh it's a
thick various door handle for the
Roadster oh yeah yeah you slide your
finger down your hat tops I mean who
knows that's this is stranded
but it's not it's not using that
steering wheel I don't know why they do
that they do that for concept cars that
no sideview mirrors which now is
actually becoming legal which is great I
have no sideview mirrors because it
looks sexier
but so what it looks more sleek does it
really bother you that's like if you get
dude and girls really hot but she has a
chipped tooth oh no no no that makes it
that makes that makes it better that's
like that's character man that's
beautiful so why do you need why don't
you want side mirrors I want to see it
just creates a cleaner line [ __ ] a clean
line I wanna see what's going on what
have you died I wanna see what's behind
me man well the new Honda all-electric
car that's basically kind of like a like
a golf kind of an e golf but it's a
fully new car it's got it's got the
camera system with the side view mirrors
they're just right on the edge of the
dash right where the mirrors kind of
would be and the guy the guy who was
doing a review of it one of the few guys
who's gotten to drive it said that it
just blows you away you're like why have
a car has been like this forever because
it gives you an accurate full time view
of what's going on and the rear view
mirror is also a screen with no colors
no pillars what what are you laughing at
making fun of this car in it no go back
to the house look at this well joy some
Honda it's cute II also got the most
ridiculous turning radius it's turns
tighter than a London cab yeah because
it's got a stick in the ground yeah just
it just plants a pole in the ground it
just rotates yeah yeah the roadster is
is evil I don't think it's really gonna
come out in 2020 I don't think so either
I think it's gonna get pushed back yeah
but it's just such a gorgeous
it does have some active Aero I think in
the spoilers active it's nice cool
looking it looks like what a car
supposed to look like in 2020 exactly
[Applause]